good afternoon I have today left
hospital after a week in which the NHS
has saved my life no question it's hard
to find words to express my debt but
before I come to that I want to thank
everyone in the entire UK for the effort
and the sacrifice you have made and are
making when the Sun is out and the kids
are at home when the whole natural world
seems that its loveliest and the
outdoors is so inviting I can only
imagine how tough it has been to follow
the rules on social distancing I thank
you because so many millions and
millions of people across this country
have been doing the right thing millions
going through the hardship of
self-isolation faithfully patiently and
with thought and care for others as well
as for themselves I want you to know
that this Easter Sunday I do believe
that your efforts are worth it and our
daily proving their worth because
although we mourn everyday those who are
taken from us in such numbers and though
the struggle is by no means over we are
now making progress in this incredible
national battle against coronavirus
fight we never picked against an enemy
we still don't entirely understand we're
making progress in this national battle
because the British public formed a
human shield around this country's
greatest national asset our National
Health Service we understood and we
decided that if together we could keep
our NHS safe if we could stop our NHS
from being overwhelmed then we could not
be beaten and this country would rise
together and overcome this challenge as
we have overcome so many challenges in
the past in the last seven days I have
of course seen the pressure that the NHS
is under
I've seen the personal courage not just
of the doctors and nurses but of
everyone the cleaners the cooks the
health care workers of every description
physios radiographers pharmacists who've
kept coming to work kept putting
themselves in harm's way
kept risking this deadly virus it is
thanks to that courage that devotion
that duty and that love that our NHS has
been unbeatable I want to pay my own
thanks to the utterly brilliant doctors
leaders in their fields men and women
but several of them for some reason
called Nick who took some crucial
decisions a few days ago which I would
be grateful for the rest of my life I
want to thank the many nurses men and
women whose care has been so astonishing
I'm gonna forget some names so please
forgive me but I want to thank polling
and Shannon and Emily and angel and
Connie and Becky and Rachel and Nikki
and Anne and I hope they won't mind if I
mention in particular two nurses who
stood by my bedside for 48 hours when
things could have gone either way there
Jenny from New Zealand in the Cargill on
the South Island to be exact and Luis
from Portugal near Porto and the reason
in the end my body did start to get
enough oxygen was because for every
second of the night they were watching
and they were thinking and they were
caring and making the interventions I
needed so that is how I also know that
across this country 24 hours a day for
every second of every hour there are
hundreds of thousands of NHS staff who
are acting with the same care and
thought and procedure
as Jenny and Lewis that is why we will
defeat this coronavirus and defeated
together we will win because our NHS is
the beating heart of this country it is
the best of this country it is
unconquered ball it is powered by love
so thank you from me from all of us to
the NHS let's remember to follow the
rules on social distancing stay at home
protect our NHS and save lives
thank you and Happy Easter